[Music]
hey guys it's episode 177
of congratulations
[Music]
what's up you guys episode 177
um you know never thought i'd be this
far
in never thought i'd have this many
episodes of this podcast
uh back after a long [ __ ] break
anything good on quibby
do you guys know um
i do see people sometimes though and
they [ __ ]
will be like hey man did you hear about
this and it's like dude i'm not
dead you know i'm not underground
dude i feel like they thought i was at
the same hiding place as bin laden and i
come out and they're like dude have you
heard about
[ __ ] kovid i'm like i know you know
you gotta wear two masks now oh yeah
you gotta wear two masks now because
it's 90 percent
effective rather than 70 with the one
mask
if you were half a mask it's 35
um i'm just gonna put on [ __ ] eight
masks that's what i'm gonna do that's
what i've been doing actually
that's why i haven't been spotted out
i've been i've been i've
i have eight masks and i don't even have
them all around my mouth i have four
around my mouth and then i have one over
my eyes
and then one on over my neck and then
one pull
uh pushes my hair back um
are you uh so yeah so look i don't even
know how to [ __ ] do a podcast anymore
but
uh uh
what what has god it man i mean you know
what the [ __ ] do i even what have i been
doing
okay so well i have a dude my son is one
almost in one day or whatever
two days i don't even know i don't know
when this is gonna come out but one
years old man or one year old i guess
and uh my god man
like the thing that just grounds you you
know what i mean
like this this this
this kid came out of my fiance
and it's just immediate you know what i
will say my buddy once told me
he was like isn't it crazy when your kid
comes out
you just immediately would uh lay down
in front of a truck for him to save his
life
and i and i i had that in my head for
like 15 years you know
his kid's like 15 years old now but he
told me when when he when he first came
out
as it came out like it's a [ __ ]
single it's a it's a human but
um yeah and uh i
uh i thought about that and i was like
oh man that's wild to feel that like i
trusted him and [ __ ]
and then when my son came out i was just
like oh it's a [ __ ] baby i love him
and i started crying immediately
and um it was great man
but i was like would i lay down in front
of a truck for him
and i was like really conflicted because
i really wanted to feel that so i didn't
even know if i really did feel that or
not
and in one month it was just like
man i would end my life for his isn't
that crazy like i'm not even trying to
be like
any cute or anything but like
man my son like take my life so he can
live another [ __ ] day
isn't that [ __ ] crazy my dad used to
tell that about me
and you should tell that about my
brother and i felt a little bit [ __ ]
you know i would like it like when he
would say yeah like
when i would say dad would you like one
time i was at my uh we were on
vacation or some [ __ ] we were in a
building and we were on the
overhang uh on the balcony and i
and i looked down to the bottom and i
said dad do you think if i jumped down
there i would kill him it would kill me
and he said yeah probably you'd at least
break your legs and i said what would
you do if i fell
and he said i would jump too and try to
i would jump down true and try to break
tren i would jump cool running this
[ __ ] beautiful story
i would drop that hey the words [ __ ]
jump not trump
hey yes dude the words [ __ ]
jump man drum
my dad said i would jump down too and
try to break your fall and i said you
couldn't do that and he said well i
would try
um and now because i said drunk nine
times i forget what the [ __ ] point of
the goddamn story was but the truth is
um i would drum anywhere for my son
um my uh and anyway dude it's it's
really
you know some people listen to this
podcast and they don't have kids and
some people listen to this podcast and
they do have kids
i get it now it's just unreal man
i wake up and i we we go and get him
and he's just happy now he's like he
does this thing where he [ __ ]
you know he claps now
and he does this thing where he doesn't
really he doesn't say words yet but
he'll go
and naturally you know you worry about
that because you're like is this kid
just gonna be like a [ __ ] somebody in
an african tribe like is that how he's
gonna communicate from now on
what's that mean it means welcome
and you're just like ah what are they
saying well they're saying if you don't
um
abide by their traditions they'll murder
you oh [ __ ] really yeah they'll cut off
your
they'll cut off your [ __ ] well i don't
have a [ __ ] well they'll cut off your
boss okay cool
i'll tell them i don't want that you
tell them okay i guess
don't cut off my balls and so um
and so uh yeah so he goes a lot
and uh doesn't really say any words i
look at him and i say ball
ball and i do it like 90 times and he's
just sitting there looking at it and
then i wave at me
like he's in an old person's home like
he's a 90 year old in an old person's
home
just waving and you're just like you
know he had a good life he forgot where
he forgot who he is honestly
he thinks he's [ __ ] robert de niro
just waving
while i'm while i'm ball ball just
waving
[Laughter]
um but the kid smiles dude
and man we like everybody is just like
oh it's so hard to have
kids it [ __ ] up your sleep dude guess
what man my son came home from the
hospital
slept through the night never wakes up
he never wakes up in the middle of the
night
the kid sleeps from [ __ ] nine till
ten and i don't mean nine pm till ten pm
i mean nine pm
to 10 am dude the guy sleeps all night
the [ __ ] is gangster at sleeping
i check on the [ __ ] nanite every time
i look he's just like in a different
position he looks like he's
doing a slam dunk only laying on his
back or side
um so yeah the craziest thing about
having a kid man i had a kid
we had this we had the boy his name's
calvin
and we called him cali and uh
so we had we had him and
every the whole world stopped shut down
covet boom
i [ __ ] you not the kid hasn't met
another he
dude he knows nine people my son knows
nine [ __ ] people it's he's been alive
almost a year he knows nine people and
four of them have the last name dalia
dude it's unreal the kid has met
he doesn't even he thinks like there's
he he sees like a tenth person and he
just cries
he doesn't understand he sees that he
the ninth person he met he cried for an
hour and a half he was just like
how many people are in this world
how many people are here
are you kidding me oh [ __ ] another
one
that's what he's like eighth and ninth
person he was like
nine i can't even count that many but
it's
how what is this
um yeah dude here we were we were at the
park
and he [ __ ] saw two uh he saw two
babies he didn't i think he [ __ ]
thinks he's a dog
dude we have three dogs they're all
there we have four dogs one
three of them are the same size as him i
think he thinks he's one of them
because the kid just literally does what
the dogs
do all day long he just runs around and
goes
and then [ __ ] shits himself sometimes
it's un oh and he also goes to the dog
ball and [ __ ] smacks the [ __ ] out of
it
and gets all wet he's seen he we were
brought into the park
dude we brought him the park and he saw
two other babies
and he was like what is that hume well
it's that little man
dude he doesn't even understand he's the
little man too he said what's that
little man i'm a dog
[Laughter]
i'm a dog okay i don't know what the
hell that thing is
but what is that little man it looks
like oh man shrunk
what is that dude him and by the way the
other two babies didn't see babies
either they all look at each other like
the [ __ ] spider-man meme where
spider-man's looking at the other two
spider-mans
like what the [ __ ] is this who are you
that's what they were [ __ ] looking at
what the heck are you guys what are you
doing
you guys i'm a they're all thinking i'm
a dog what are you guys
unbelievable dude it was for real he
stopped dead in his track and looked at
tracks
looking at it he was looking at the
other babies like [ __ ] james spain or
was james spader was looking at the
[ __ ] uh
the portal in that movie the abyss
dork um
i uh i don't know man a lot's been going
a lot's been
going on you know nothing has been going
on what am i talking about literally
nothing i [ __ ]
get up oh my god dude
depression is real
i mean dude jesus christ i know i like
i'm in like podcast mode right now but i
just this is a front man
jesus christ i'm trying here
really i'm just trying to get to some
semblance of a [ __ ]
normalcy i wake up and i the only thing
i do is
is is play with my son
talk with my talk with kristen and just
[ __ ]
work out in my garage like
like i'm a [ __ ]
john claude van damme character in in
captivity
just with the tub filling the tub up
with the water and putting a rope around
it and just lifting it up just like son
of a [ __ ] this is what we got
do you remember that what was that movie
where you [ __ ] filled up the tub he
was in captivity and they had a tub for
some reason in the jail
like what what is this the [ __ ] four
seasons penitentiary
he hit a tub and they gave him rope who
gives [ __ ] people
rope in jail and he just tied it around
his self
and then tied around the tub and then
filled up the tub and would like
do deadlifts with the tub
[ __ ] movies you know
jesus you know i won't have to worry
about [ __ ] that anytime soon um
so i bro they [ __ ] cut me out of [ __ ]
i did
favors i did favors for people somebody
was like hey
will you be in my movie i was like ah
[ __ ] all right they cut me out of
that [ __ ]
i did fake i did favors for friends i
had friends calling me
just like hey man so listen what you
know that favor you did for me yeah
yeah we're just gonna we are not gonna
it's too much
dude like what is this world oh okay
cool you mean that day i [ __ ] came
down to all the way to malibu so i could
stand in a hot basement for
eight hours in a day and do one scene
are you gonna cut me out of that okay
cool i think [ __ ] jesus god damn they
they took the worst part the worst the
worst though is that they took my
[ __ ]
they took my beat bobby flay episode off
of youtube that was really detrimental
to my [ __ ] mental
um uh
yeah well wow dude but i got a [ __ ]
talk i guess you know
um
and [ __ ] it dude this is still brought
to you by my undies i don't give a [ __ ]
what they say uh so
i dude speaking of dude i thought about
this
[ __ ] one time in the last eight
months one time me and my [ __ ]
brother we went to i was this by the way
this is something that i don't know if
this is a thing or not but i always
imagined it was a thing
like for some reason when i was like i
guess i would i must have been like
i must have been older than i don't know
if i still lived in new jersey or what
but we were in
la because our friends had moved there
and we it was his birthday and we
gave him sanjo san jose
sharks boxers okay that was his birthday
gift and and i remember when we got him
it my mom was like what do you want to
get him and we got him and and and we
were in a store
and there were all these cool boxers and
it felt like boxers were like a new
thing or maybe they started just making
prints and [ __ ]
of like team prints she said what team
do you want to get we're like let's get
him
santa we wanted to get him like the la
team but
didn't la not have a team back then or
something another raiders
but they didn't have them so we ended up
getting the [ __ ] san jose sharks
we're like that's close enough i was
like cool they're blue that's nice so we
got them boxers and we brought them and
we were like
was box just like a new thing the boxers
were around in like the 40s those
[ __ ] guys who were fake strong used
to wear them all the time in the black
and white shows
you know the guys that would do this a
lot or lift the barbell with the two big
spheres on it
as dangerous and so um
uh so we got him the boxers and we went
to san marino i think is where they
lived and we gave it to him and we're
like yeah they're boxer shorts and he
thought
you could wear them as shorts too
or boxers and he was like the cool thing
about these is you can wear these
under pants or also they can be your
pants
and i was like really and he was like
yup
he was like let's go to the store let's
walk to the candy store and so we
[ __ ] walked to the candy store
and he just he just four [ __ ] boxers
like he just had a shirt on
and san jose sharks boxers
dude the kid was 12 walking to the candy
store with just
boxers on and
uh that's something i [ __ ] thought
about in the past eight months so i'm
telling it to you guys
but dude that's uh oh god i can't wait
to [ __ ] live that kind of [ __ ] with
my kid just to be like
i talked to my dad now you know and i
just i asked him about
[ __ ] you know about like is it okay if
this and that and he's just like it's
fine like dude
cal kelly hits his [ __ ] head on
everything
he'll just [ __ ] be standing there and
he'll just be like see ya
and just do like what's the [ __ ]
what's the thing in my head where a guy
the image of the guy where he just oh
oh what's the [ __ ] image where what's
the movie where the guy's
holding on to the guy and then he just
let's go
it's the [ __ ] and he smiles and lets
go
[ __ ] whatever it is that's what cal
does dude there was one time where he
was
kelly was he had the [ __ ] uh he had
this
this string that my my mom gave him a
present and he unwrapped it with this
string
and he didn't give a [ __ ] about the
president but he just liked the string
so he tied it around his wrist
and there was one time where he just
took it and and and looked at it
and he go and he went like this and he
and he pulled it across like this
and we went whoa and he smiled and he
just literally went like this
and [ __ ] tiptoed back and i used my
mongoose-like reflexes to [ __ ] scoop
him up and he was safe and i'm a [ __ ]
hero for that
um i love him so much dude
he's almost a year old i can't believe
it i'll post some pictures of him
probably
i don't know how i felt about that
earlier but it just he's so sweet and i
just
um he's just great
he takes my my glasses off all the time
in the morning he'll just be like he'll
grab him and then put him in his mouth
i'll be like i need those and i'll put
him back on and i'll just do him again
and just laugh
dude how about having a life where you
just think that that's funny
over and [ __ ] over again we were
watching blue's clues
the other day and the [ __ ] josh guy
was just going
bing bing bing on his guitar and callie
would just go
and then he would go ping ping ping ping
and keller will go
[Laughter]
bing bing bing dude that show it's i
can't even watch that [ __ ] these
children shows
even with my kid because like it's like
they make it's so easy to figure this
[ __ ] out and even though my kid doesn't
even know how to talk
and all he does is go it still is like
we'll watch bubble guppies and it'll be
like hey
we need to it'll be like hey we need to
[ __ ]
when you see the blue ladybug
set say there it is and it's just like a
blank screen with a blue ladybug on it
and i'm like [ __ ]
it's right there and and cal
calvin's just like and i'm like you know
it's there right because i want him to
know what's there even though he's
[ __ ] too young i want him to know
that it's [ __ ] there and then the
bubble guppies are like
hmm looking
the bubble guppies show kind of [ __ ]
pisses me off because they're f
dude because they have no legs and
they're floating around in the water but
also they're outside not in the water
floating around so it's like pick one
bubble guppies you know what i'm talking
about
and uh professor flounder or whatever
the [ __ ] the teacher is named grouper mr
grouper
that guy's like you know
they're just in the children's show this
is what i think about the children's
shows is that everybody's just a little
too stupid all the characters are just a
little too stupid
you know he'll be like hmm how would i
get my hair
cut would i go to the would i go to the
hospital or the barber
and it's just like i know you're doing
it for the kids but the kids should be
looking at the guy
and the guy should be leading the kid
the kid shouldn't be like
you don't know excuse me 45 year old guy
who's doing a voice for a [ __ ] fish
you don't know
hmm i'm hungry should i eat
cooked chicken or a shopping cart
and anytime my son is like you don't
know
you don't know
maybe i'll eat both [ __ ] eat both so
we could sue the bubble guppies
um yeah dude but so the bubble guppies i
don't know
there's another show too that's [ __ ]
blue's clues is cool i think josh
is cool um
kristen [ __ ] loves josh she thinks
he's like cool
she looked him up on instagram and [ __ ]
he's cool i guess he played aladdin in
the um
in the [ __ ] on broadway which
good thing you already did that because
i think now you could probably get
cancer for that because he's filipino i
think it needs to be he needs to be an
actual
anyway um oh at least i don't have to
worry about what i say anymore
um i was just like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna get
heat
whatever um i uh yeah dude
so uh i've let's see
i just watched [ __ ] so many shows man
that was like my
home for a while like i was so and
am still so broken and upset and
depressed and sad
that like i live man dude i
my last question was called no pain
because i didn't have any [ __ ] pain
in my life
and it's so funny because people will
come up to me and this is a very david
brent moment but like people come up to
me and they say hey like your comedy got
me through some rough times
i would watch your [ __ ] i would watch
your podcast i would just stand up
when i was going through a rough time
and i would take my mind off it and i
never understood that i never [ __ ]
got that man
i never understood that i would be like
well could you just like think about
whatever in your head or like
convince yourself you're not upset bro
the answer is
no and i'm 40 years old i didn't know
that [ __ ] but now i've got
depth bro i'm in so much
[ __ ] pain and yeah it's hilarious
like on the i understand the humor in it
but man let me tell you
the joy i would get the [ __ ]
joy i would get from watching lost
or [ __ ] love island just the joy i
would get from watching love island to
watch these [ __ ]
idiots just like yeah i guess i'll
couple up with her now
because i got i got mugged dude i
watched
do you guys watch this love island show
by the way i watch it every night
and there's six seasons of the british
ones two seasons in the australian ones
and i think three seasons are two
seasons of the american ones
now i only watched a little bit of the
american one because
americans are just kind of [ __ ]
i hate saying this dude because my
friend is always like loves british [ __ ]
and i'm always like bro just be british
just be [ __ ] british if you love
british people so much you know
my friend all the guy has to do is come
out in like a [ __ ]
high turtleneck and be like i don't know
how are you and he's like dude this guy
this guy's great all the guy has to do
is be smoking a pipe in a row and that's
to say like all right cheerio then and
my buddy's like
dude what's up with man how come
americans aren't like this
but i'm telling you right now the
[ __ ] british and australian versions
of love island
man i watched this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was my church you understand it was
my okay everything's gonna be okay
i'd watch these [ __ ] characters
i don't even i just wanna [ __ ] have a
love island podcast is what i want to
have
that's how much i love this show and i
[ __ ] hate reality tv
i hate it i hate it i hate reality tv
the kardashians
i don't care i gotta i gotta like the
fact that the kardashians are so
famous and now i have to hear about them
every single [ __ ] day of my life
because they just have a reality show
and everybody [ __ ] knows
knows them and now i gotta be like oh
she tweeted this kanye tweeted that
kris jenner tweeted this the [ __ ]
other one tweeted that
i don't even know who they are but i
know who they are you know
so now i gotta [ __ ] i hate reality
all the the bachelor i i
you know i watched the bachelor i
watched the new bachelor at or the one
with the girl
with all the guys i like watching them
with the girl with all the guys i don't
like watching all the girls with the guy
but uh whatever that one is so we
watched that now it's like i don't
really care
you know but love island dude the
[ __ ]
show is brutal people like the british
one better than the australian one but
the australian one
i like a lot because of the certain
characters that i [ __ ] fell for
dude there's a guy named jackson in this
love island australia that is
hey man okay so
[ __ ] i this is a real thing i'm
describing okay
he is a guy
who looks just like charlie hunnam
like people on love island thought he
was charlie hunnam and thought that he
was lying about
who he was which is idiot you can tell
if it's charlie hunnam or not just by
using
looking uh
but you didn't okay fine some people
have that facial recognition thing where
they can't [ __ ] understand who anyone
is just by looking at their faces they
need to like look at their clothes and
also see names and hear their voices
okay maybe that's you if it is
fix yourself but still if that's how you
are
change it and fix yourself but fine
my buddy swears that he has [ __ ] that
and he's just like i don't know who that
is man i'm just like you've met him nine
times and he's just like
i have that thing where i can't
understand who someone is because of
their face i need to hear their voice
and i need to see
what they're doing i'm like all right
dude
he also thinks he thinks he has that
thing where he can feel colors which is
[ __ ]
not a thing so anyway
this guy looks just like [ __ ] charlie
hunnam
and he acts like charlie hunnam
and his name is jackson
and charlie hunnam's character in sons
of anarchy
is named jackson k
and his last name
is human
dude his last name
uh dude
you changed your name to jackson because
charlie hunnam's character's name
in [ __ ] sons of anarchy
his name is jackson and you changed your
last name to human
uh just do it just change your whole
thing
to charlie hunnam that that would be the
[ __ ]
dude if you legally changed your name to
just charlie hunnam
and you looked like him but here's the
[ __ ] best part about the whole thing
dude he has a [ __ ] sons of anarchy
back tattoo that's the size of a goat
okay it's the size of a [ __ ]
armadillo and it's on the back
and it says sons of anarchy
ha and that's all good but ha
okay you got his sons of anarchy tattoo
sides of an armadillo on your back now
it's all good but also
ah now choo doon
and he's a [ __ ] stripper that's it
dude that's it he's a stripper and he
did a stripper dance to one of the girls
and when he did it
he [ __ ] came out with a slide like an
usher slide
and his hair which was gelled back
[ __ ]
jutted forward a little bit and i fell
down i fell down
dude nothing is
funnier than a guy who thinks he's the
[ __ ]
nothing is funnier than the guy who
thinks he's playing it cool when he's
not
and he's the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude and on the british love island
there's a guy okay dude you gotta
[ __ ] listen to me man this reality
show is the best [ __ ] reality show
there's a guy in love island that is a
[ __ ]
dude he's coupled up with this girl he
falls in love with this girl and he's so
insecure and he's always trying to make
sure the girl likes him and [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] producers of love island
put the [ __ ]
put his ex they introduce his ex on the
island so now
the x is on the island and he's trying
to make sure
that the girl is okay and he's all like
no it's cool it's my ex i'm all over her
it's fine but we're all
over everything's over it's fine i'm
with my new girl now and he starts
the way he plays it cool i have to play
you the just the audio of it
just the audio of it i texted it to my
friends
last night and i said
this is the funniest thing that has ever
happened on tv [ __ ] and i'm
gonna show you it but i need to
give you context first so this guy fell
in love with this girl on love island
and has been dating her for three weeks
and every now and then they introduce a
new guy or girl on love island and it
really shakes things up because it tests
people's relationships obviously
so three and a half weeks into this show
this guy who fell in love with this
girl's
ex shows up on love island his current
girl is pissed naturally and he's trying
to make sure she's okay and reassure her
but this dude obviously is really shook
by his ex showing up
and still has at least some feelings for
her
so he's walking away with his current
girl trying to make sure she's okay and
this is what happens
his name is tom so i'm just gonna play
the audio of it
there's nothing i think is fun that is
funnier than this type of thing
i think if you listen to this podcast
you know that's good
to get back
so is it gonna bother you is it gonna
bother you not at all
hey everyone let's watch tom being not
[Music]
bothered
[Laughter]
bro okay
nah that's fine i don't care i don't
care it's all good it's all good all
right good okay good she she
walks into the other room let's talk
about you and me let's talk about all
the good things and the bad thing why'd
you stop being so happy about he's like
no i'm just not bothered
oh so bothered
dude if you're a guy and you start to
[ __ ]
say nah shit's cool and then you sing a
song
you might as well say hey
i'm about to cry
if i was like i lost my job the best
thing ever happened to me though isn't
that cool
you raised me up if i was on
[ __ ] mountains you'd be like hey
that guy is about to cry if i was like
yeah my dad just died but it's all good
we've had weird
issues and it's probably better off this
way
what's the song
hey dude you know what my [ __ ] chops
aren't as good as they were
i could literally only think of a josh
groban song so that's cool
yay hey my dad's all good
oh yeah okay cool what's that [ __ ]
dude he sang the [ __ ] salt and pepper
song of all songs let's talk about
and me let's talk about all the good
things and the bad things that may be
let's talk about sex
or just what's the [ __ ] hey yeah my
dad died but it's all good we had
[ __ ] unresolved issues and i'm
probably better off that way it's just a
weight off my shoulders really
yup
oh he's about to cry just walking in the
field with a leather jacket on him
anyway dude that show is a [ __ ] laugh
i love how british dudes call [ __ ]
girls birds you know
disrespectful yeah i could nick a bird
couldn't i
hit yeah you know you catch me at a club
i'll nick a bird
really yeah hey that's an animal
now talking about one of those [ __ ]
parrots
i mean what bird are you even talking
about it's so shitty you know
yeah you know [ __ ] penguin
you know she's fat on the bottom you
know she walks around like a [ __ ]
like she's squashing ants
[Laughter]
dude my mom has one friend that waddles
she [ __ ] holds her purse and she
walks like that
um but yeah no what the [ __ ] was i
talking about the
the the [ __ ] birds it's an animal
dude
how do how do british women let men get
away with that [ __ ]
yeah i could nick a bird at a club
any other animal awful yeah
yeah there's some [ __ ] pigs coming
this way look at that
yeah i can't wait to [ __ ] a pig
yeah yeah she's a dirty pig rolling
around and [ __ ]
in it like a [ __ ] pig hey look three
pigs coming up
just so shitty yeah look rats
hey look bird for some reason is nice
maybe birds are pretty they're not all
pretty though they got thin necks
sometimes
i watched breaking bad that show's so
[ __ ] good i watched
lost that show's my favorite show dude
ever
i watched lost kristen would get so mad
and be like again
dude she doesn't want to binge [ __ ] when
i [ __ ] find a show i like i like like
one percent of shows cause all shows
pretty much [ __ ] blow dicks
you know all shows are just
they're like it's like the music tells
you how to feel and the [ __ ] and they're
all indicating all the actors are like
yeah i'd like that and you're like
nobody says that [ __ ]
i just i i don't know i you know
or they're saying [ __ ] like oh this
isn't how it's a or
you know it's just
i mean they got [ __ ] queen latifah
playing the equalizer she's
50. oh she's just like a 50 year old
woman doing
like [ __ ] roundhouse kicks unlike
healthy 28 year old men
and you go on twitter and people are
just like hell yeah
more of this
are people in the midwest watching this
[ __ ] and then no
there's people in the [ __ ] that part
of oklahoma that's that little sliver
they're like what the [ __ ] is going on
what is this [ __ ]
you know what the [ __ ] is going on here
that ain't denzel
you got a [ __ ] lady on here she's 50.
she looks like she should be behind a
desk at a bank
she did a [ __ ] roundhouse kick on a
28 year old
guy that looks like zangief what the
[ __ ]
she's just some lady that looks like a
[ __ ] live i'm sorry dude she looks
like a librarian man
and she's just gonna come out and if you
need help
i'm the one if i need help with what
filing books
if i need help with what
it's like dude it's so overly correct
we'll get a black 50 year old lady to
play the [ __ ] equalizer
she'll set she'll set [ __ ] straight
i swear to god dude everyone's [ __ ]
okay all right fine you know what it is
just as unbelievable as [ __ ] denzel
doing all the [ __ ] that he does
in the equalizer but at least like
oh we gotta we gotta we gotta
we gotta we gotta now she can kick ass
i'm sure she could beat anybody up
that's fine it's fine
that's the thing make the show wonder
woman that's the thing that's my
argument
make it she has super powers that's the
thing
if it's not jason statham or the rock or
[ __ ] liam neeson
make it be a [ __ ] someone with
superpowers you know
like there's some guys i don't even
believe the [ __ ] on
what's his what's his name uh
like tom holland he's spider-man there
you go
that's good he's got super powers i
believe it
you put tom holland in [ __ ] equalizer
like what's this guy doing he should be
nicking bads
um
i don't know
my son
it's crazy to think that i have a kid
now man
like you know when you have a kid and
you're just like wow i have a [ __ ]
kid when does that go away
it's been 11 almost 12 months
and like i miss him now
he is so great
like when i
think about him i watch you know i watch
videos of him like when i
i go i do one thing every day i go get
a coffee and i and i drive back home and
i sometimes i'll wear my foot
from my coffee i just look at videos of
him and i just [ __ ] am smiling like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so weird
i used to spend that time like looking
at [ __ ] porn or chicks or some [ __ ]
and uh
it's weird to think like i think this
boy saved my life man
i i uh
it's not like anything else you can't
you can't compare it to anything else
for those of you that don't have kids
it's like football's like baseball it's
a sport
you know coffee is like
you drink oh yeah what's it like you'd
be like yeah it's like a [ __ ] you
know you've had other drinks but having
a kid isn't like anything
you can be like is it like having a pet
and you're like no it's not it's nothing
like that it's its own thing
um
he is uh
he's so cool um i'm gonna post some
pictures of him i think on instagram
in a little bit if you want to check it
out
because it's what i've been up to he
looks like me too dude
he's got the eyebrows immediately had
the eyebrows it was just like a
no-brainer that he was he was my kid
if you ever had to worry about that this
wasn't one of those times
and he [ __ ] knows what's up too he
does like
he'll make you laugh and then make you
laugh again it's crazy i don't mean to
be i'm being born i'm being one of those
[ __ ] dads
um yeah i don't know
i don't even know if i [ __ ] how long
has it been
40 i guess i could go for a little bit
longer
this guy made this book he sent it to me
which means a lot by the way
you know i know i've been out and i
haven't been online really that
that much at all but i have gotten some
messages
and a lot of you guys have been really
sweet and i really uh
i really uh i really you know those
messages
make you feel really because man i got
[ __ ]
[ __ ] by my friends my friends just
didn't give a [ __ ] a lot of them
you know hollywood's crazy
yeah that was really hard to deal with
and it is it is really hard to deal with
but um
you know i think some people didn't
reach out because uh
they thought they didn't want to bother
me but those of you that did
you know who you are and uh
it helped man
but uh yeah this book got sent to me
this guy sent this book
um rob
he sent me a note which was really sweet
and he made this
uh congratulations log gabbit rule book
volume one which is uh
it's funny man and i was reading this
[ __ ] and some of the [ __ ] i said is so
dumb you know i'm like an
idiot and the fact that like you like
some people like it is just uh
humbling uh but anyway i don't know i
think he made like three of them and he
gave me one of them
anyway i read it to calvin every night
before he goes to bed just so he knows
the [ __ ] room
[Music]
son it's time for bed let's open up the
congratulations rule book
let's let's let's let's do this
just remember son rule 241 if you know
what day it is you have a [ __ ] office
job
good night like like this the [ __ ] i
said
just remember son you [ __ ] putting
coffee scrub on your body in the shower
you're hooking good night
ding ding ding
[Applause]
[Music]
dude everybody's looking
for blue's clues i'll [ __ ] sing it in
the shower i don't give a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] kristen knows all the words
i don't know how the [ __ ] she knows all
the words because i just hear the
[ __ ] notes and she's just
like step by step clue back clue
and i'm just like how do you know it
she's like i hear it all the time i'm
like i hear it all the time too but i
don't know this [ __ ]
um anyway
i guess that's it man i don't know i'll
do another one i think i'm gonna
probably put some of this [ __ ] on
patreon
um because i don't have you know i don't
have [ __ ] sponsors
it is [ __ ] crazy the [ __ ] that
happened um and i'll probably get
dragged for saying
stuff like that all good man
what else can you take uh
i got all that matters got my fam uh
and thanks for listening dude i'll do
another episode in a week
or whatever and i think i'm gonna set
something up where like
i'll do a patreon and maybe like you'll
have a an episode a month or two
episodes a month
at a certain tier but i'll get that
going
um and i'll talk more about this whole
[ __ ] thing my journey and whatever
the [ __ ]
i hate when people say yeah my journey
like everyone is uh
in that everyone is a brendan fraser
character
but i um yeah i don't know i just had to
get back to it man i haven't
done a podcast dude and i wanted to post
[ __ ] and but man i was just so down and
i still am but like
i don't know i figure
you got to start sometime and shout out
to all of the friends and oh and and the
fans too man you guys like a lot of you
guys wrote me and were
sweet but man shout out to the friends
that [ __ ] kept checking in and
texting me
thanks for listening and uh you guys
uh i'll talk i'll talk to you soon
okay bye
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
you